[Music]
hey babe
hey babe hey babe
what's up everybody welcome to hey babe
how are you i'm doing good how are you
doing i'm doing good you know
things are good i just i had some coffee
i'm
uh we made some coffee downstairs and
then we put a little bailey's in
and i got to be honest with you it's i
feel i'm buzzed
i feel buzzed right coffee's with bailey
i was specifically told by my doctor
yesterday
that my blood pressure is getting to the
level where i will need medication the
next three months and the number one
thing to do is avoid alcohol and coffee
so i mix them and i said you know what
doc i'm going to do what i want to do
yeah and i'm now i'm drinking bailey's
and coffee because
you have some because you don't have a
keurig machine you have a you have one
of the machines that like you're like a
barista
yeah down there and then you gave me
bailey's i'm as close to a barista as
you're going to get you close the
baristas you're going to get yeah
and i had what's called what's known in
the hood as an irish coffee
you had an irish you had a yeah well you
didn't have the whiskey though
usually irish coffee has irish whiskey
in it but i had the baileys
but i thought bailey's i thought it was
baileys and coffee
uh am i wrong i think this variant i
think an irish coffee for me first and
foremost
is a little um irish whiskey a little
creme de menthe
little whipped cream and a little creme
de menthe drizzle on top creme de menthe
drizzle
yeah i am i don't know if you know this
i am
a licensed bartender i didn't know that
like i actually went to bartending
school and got a license
oh you really did yeah oh wow i know
here's another we should hang them up on
the wall
we should have a wall of accolades
behind us i'd like to make an addendum
to it because i got
a hundred on the bartending exam my
certificate said specifically
licensed bartender and mixologist
because i got 100 what was this i did
this in 2000
i was dating a girl whose father owned
boats and he said in order to work on
the boats
you have to become a licensed bartender
so i went to the barton school so this
must have been 2006
and then it's one of the stories i told
you where yeah somebody got thrown off
the boat
for the russian body yeah finish him i i
i did in 2003.
i loved the experience yeah i went up
birth control
no i don't know what that is actually
you know what's so funny i thought i
shut off all my mind
what's the alarm number two meal number
two well
there it is right here you got some
alcohol too yeah i poured myself a
little you notice it's a sunday
afternoon
yeah it's a lazy sun and whatever day
you're watching this just make it a
sunday afternoon yeah make it a sunday
afternoon
on the east coast wherever you're
watching you could be watching this from
islamabad pakistan right which we have
fans there
make it a sunday afternoon on the east
coast now the reason i'm mentioning
islamabad is
why is because you started watching
homeland and i do have a bartending
school story as well but this is always
the nature of this podcast
let's go into homeland i can come back
to the let me tell you something
i wouldn't say i've been watching
homeland i
would say my life has become homeland
i've been consumed by homeland
i'm not 100 sure we're not being
recorded on top of the camera devices we
have in the room yes i think there also
could be fbi plans
chilling chilling i'm not sure who you
work for what age you work for me
yeah genuinely it's become that kind of
show
which by the way cause for the last 10
years as most people have been saying
i'm watching homeland
i've woke up most days and said where
the hell is claire dayne's been
yeah that's where she's been pal that's
where she's been big she puts all her
eggs in that basket
which is a big basket let me tell you
something i watched that show and for
those who don't you're moving your neck
around a lot and it's concerning me
because i was a licensed physical
therapist for many years
and i'm sensing stiff neck and pain
you're right i
twisted my neck while i was sleeping you
twisted your neck yeah i've applied
no less than four topical ointments on
it today right
from varying companies i did i did a icy
hot
regular strength okay i did an icy hot
with extra mental extra strength
wow i did this thing called body butter
that has a
has a cbd in it okay as an agent there
and then i did this other uh
this other oil that i was suggested to
do
and i took two advil let me tell you
zilch not working at all not really i
just feel like i have a real like numb
skin
did you wake up with it yeah with a bat
okay
it was yesterday though it was just two
days ago it's a two day it's a two day
linger
to decrease what i think shout out
cranberries cranberries
to decrease uh that's good for yeast
infections if you're at home fighting
yeasty
cranberries is the number one thing to
do uti right
cranberry juice you're right we get utis
absolutely oh we have urinary tract oh
we do 100 can get infected
i don't know i've never had a uti how do
we get a uti how does a woman get a uti
woman typically gets a uti from because
you know they're
they're really i mean the truth is
because the you know their buttholes are
close to their to their vaginals
i i'll take a hard pass on the rest of
this what it is but
depending on the length of your penis
you you know and i'm not listen there's
a lot of different people in this world
there might be some of our friends that
like to tuck it back a little bit they
with longer penises they'd be more at
risk than uti
with a small penis can't it's one of the
main reasons women get it more than men
are more common in women than two they
curve your bacteria build up somewhere
along your urinary tract
you have a bacteria i just thought like
bacteria from anywhere
it could be like the bacteria that makes
maggots
true yeah yeah i got larvae dick
[Laughter]
they they i so wait so
people are getting utis from their ass
and then you just gotta drink
an ocean spray crayon apple and you're
good that's all you gotta do every time
by the way every time i would
when i got when i went through physical
therapy school and i realized that
cranberry juice
cranberry juice is the thing that that
prevents utis and cures and
every time i would watch that ocean
spray commercial with that guy walking
through the
river of cranberries like you must have
a uti
it's the only reason why who's walking
around with the the
uh their their private area tucked to
the back
back are you walking around 100
i mean i can see if you sit down but
you're walking around and it's it's like
a you
let me tell you something i had a friend
who was an nypd detective
he still might be but he was an nyp
detective his
his um it's interesting because he told
us and he would tell us these stories
that his job was specifically his job
was to get
uh like perverts like catch perverts and
and and like
investigate like lewd behavior and he
would tell us all these stories and then
one time we met his partners they were
in the um
accounting division of the nypd and when
i was like i thought you did the lewd
behaviors they're like no
he just does the lewd behavior stuff on
his own he investigates it
but he was saying that no no i really do
do it but anyway he told us
that what he would see a lot
number one he said bo far and away
far and away the most unsafe
place to be in new york city
from sec the number the hotbed of sex
crimes
yeah in new york city take a guess are
you going to give me a neighborhood
i'm going to give you i'm going to give
you a neighborhood and a time of year
he he said it you literally he would
tell family members after you worked
there
to please wear a poncho because you
don't know where it'll be flying from
when you're in this type of when you're
in this place so it's a neighborhood and
a time of year
yes number one far and away said it's
not even close sex crimes the sex crimes
okay
i don't mean to okay not sex crimes by
the way
99 of the victims have no idea they're
even a victim of the sex crime
in this area during this time oh it's a
subway you would think
oh i know it what is it i think i know
it tell me
christmas time rockefeller center bang
that's what it is that's how you do it
that's why we can tell you guess sex
crime
questions that's why we have this
podcast we put our brains together
and we have a new segment called guess
that sex crime it's coming next week
30 rocks you go during the holidays oh i
believe it because i was
like two years ago i took my little
nephews they were visiting from
california
right and you you almost have to just be
just you get so crushed that your feet
lift off the ground and the crowd is
just pushing you in a certain way
so people are down there creatures
number one what
two two big big factors number one
crowds number two
there it is number two winter time
people wearing big jackets
a lot of the perverts and sex offenders
can hide what they're doing
underneath the jackets and only open up
when they're about to
orgasm so he said he said you skipped
like
10 spaces ahead of me let me tell you
you just passed go you collected all
sorts of money let me tell you i thought
you just meant like a grope you mean
that people are ejaculating on people
he said part of his job every day uh
during this time was to literally he
said literally i would have to go to a
family
to a woman most likely would have no
idea that somebody just
ejaculate on the back of her jacket walk
up to her and her family stop her
and say happy holidays
you have semen on the back of your
jacket you've been a victim of a sex
crime and then take
her over and the family over to a
makeshift little precinct
mobile commander that they had to then
take the semen
the sperm off her jacket put it in the
database and see if
if that guy was it was somebody they had
in their database nine times out of ten
the sperm matched instantly they knew
where to get him because he was jerking
off on the next one
so it just wouldn't stop so he's not
even looking for someone in the act
because everything is
so close together so he's just walking
around looking at
looking at three-quarter walls coats he
said looking for a jacket well i said i
said what would you do
like how would you you know find it he
said i would look around
yeah i swear to god he wasn't being
funny he was telling us we were i've
never forget we're drinking beers at
this place called o'neills and mass
spirit queens
shadow o'neill's he goes um he would he
goes i'd look around and i'd look for a
guy in a puffy jacket with his eyes
rolling in the back of his head
that's what i would look for he said i
would look because he said then you know
that there go he said you look for some
movement he he get this
gentleman wakes up takes a shower has
his coffee puts on a uniform goes
and then just starts to look for puffy
coated people with their eyes rolling
back he said literally
that's his job he's paying his mortgage
looking for people
in in a down or a synthetic puffer with
eyes rolling in the back of the head
that's his big big tail that's his big
big tail he would look for eyes
rolling in the back of his head in a
triple flat goose triple fat goose well
i don't know if they would have the
money for the triple factors if they're
you know
because sex crime guys typically i would
say maybe they have a south pole jacket
it's a burlington co-factory burlington
coal factory specimen you know whatever
so so they they would he said we look
for the eyes well he said we look for
the hand moving up and down in the coat
and then the eyes rolling in the back of
the head and then he knew
that something was about to come out and
he would go have to go over to the
family and i said you would start with
happy holidays what's the point
and he would say he would say it's
always nice to hear a well-wish no
matter who you are what are you talking
about that's what i said i said why
would you always start with happy
holidays he said you know the end my
bosses would say you know
it's christmas time it's keep it in the
christmas spirit i'm being dead serious
he would just say
so you'd have to go up and say happy
holidays you've been the victim of a sex
crime
please come with me and then he said
obviously you know you'd ruin their
christmas
you know you'd have the the husband or
the father you know
go irate and he said you know we'd have
to find them
and and do it so and but but the reason
why i bring all this up is because he
said you can't imagine also
how many not talking about christmas at
all now how many men
they would stop on the subway or they
would you know you know a sexual deviant
that they would be following
when they would go to arrest them and
and then uh
you know when you get bring them to the
precinct or bring them when they're
about to check in to
bring them to the precinct whenever we
drop them off you know you have to make
sure that they don't have any weapons on
them and they would take down their
pants and their penises were taped
like us like a vagina he said
so those are utis everywhere utis
everywhere i i that's what i said i said
so do you just have to have
antibiotics and cranberry juice right
then and then sell because it must be
uti city
right and then he didn't say anything he
just took a sip of the beer and he said
happy holidays and walked away
well let me ask you a question did we
just do a disservice because now
all the sex criminals that are watching
right we know they're watching
you know no the ingenious ways and i
don't mean
now they know um that
to to not let their eyes roll back yeah
how about this understand we're giving
them in we're giving them valuable
counter information how about this you
ready for this one he also said because
the and i i don't mean
ingenious there in any positive
connotation at all to the engine
it's just my friend said there was this
one guy what he would do
is he would walk around the city and the
only reason why they found him that's
the only reason why
this is just crazy these stories he
would find him
he said he literally would wear bad it
was the middle of the summer
he'd wear baggy like baggy like jenko
jeans from the 90s so it's like what is
these jengkol jeans
because what he had was and he would
wear a long sleeve shirt in the middle
of the summer
he had had a camera like he had it kind
of he had he had a button
like like almost like he's detonating a
bomb like which we'll talk about in
homeland he had a button that he would
press
he had a cat and he would wear these big
like doc martin boots like oversized
like rock boots
he had a camera that would on his shoe
through his pants you'd never see it and
he would walk up to women unsuspecting
women who were wearing skirts in the
middle of the summer
and take pictures of the skirt sure he
said when they found him
when they found him he had upwards of a
thousand pictures
of women underneath their skirts no way
for them really to identify he said
he said a thousand pictures and two
penises under the skirt
he said so he was taking pictures of
women that he take pictures of people he
thought were women
when he took the picture under the skirt
there was a big set of penis and balls
under there so he said so we tried to
identify them
instead of penis and balls so he said so
two out of every one thousand people are
cross-dressed
cross-dressing no idea but he said the
reason how they found him
is because also simultaneously when he
was taking the pictures for whatever
reason
and this is how they knew this is how
they got him he would then the reason
why somebody called the cops and would
alert the
uh he would take the picture with the
right hand and then the left hand would
go
in for no re again reasons unbeknownst
the reason how he would get aroused to
that is he would then
with his left hand take his finger and
start fingering his own butthole
so they found a guy walking down 42nd
street fingering his own butthole with
his left hand
which made people feel like a major tell
that's a major talent and then when they
caught him
and then what he did again this is
coming from a source i'm not making this
up try to be funny
the how he tried to get away is he took
his finger out of his butt and said i
will put this on your face
and he said it was like having a loaded
gun in a way my friend said you know
for a split second it's like having a
load of guns like if you don't listen
you're like nobody wants poo poo
on their face from a random stranger but
they're like does he have a disease does
he have hiv
they said last thing i need is pink eye
right now he said i'll put
i will touch your face with my finger
and then he said you know of course like
they came to and they just wrestled him
down
and arrested him yeah that person is not
all there either because no
i mean how far are you going to get
waving your [ __ ] finger out of court
i know
but it is something if my point is again
not that i'm advocating for crime but
it's worth the shot if you are feel like
you're the victim
of you know some type of police thing
that you weren't you didn't commit the
crime you could try to stick your finger
in your butthole and see if at least
they back up for a second and hear your
story
yeah hear your story by yourself
valuable moments if you
have you got an answer at least to give
your side of the story if you're guilty
you're guilty butthole finger or not
you're gonna go
you're going to jail he was in motion
fingering his own butthole that's how
they caught him
and that was after this guy has some
racket going on unbelievable he's got
electronics hooked up to his boots
also by the way i don't know anything
about this but like how i mean how good
pictures could those be
like people are walking pictures what
are you seeing you're seeing this
abstract
like leg go up to what so they're still
wearing clothes underneath it's like
what are you getting from that
he would wait until they stopped at he
said and he said
he would wait until and then stand right
next to him in a crowd of new york city
street
and take the picture the problem is then
he said they obviously put him in jail
but they couldn't identify any victims
because you can't identify a girl off of
a gene
i mean you know would you be able to i
wouldn't be able to or from
unmentionables unmentionable that's what
they call uh
like your your underwear your
unmentionables no don't they
is that just your part private area i
don't know
we mentioned them let's say you go
through someone's drawer and they have
all their bras and pain
aren't they those called unmentionables
i call them again
why can't you mention i call them
underwears for me
something's called an unmentionable
right is it
called unmentionables an old-fashioned
euphemism for underwear is called the
unmentionables there you go 2020. for me
unmentionables
i i just call everything underwear
whether to me underwear has no
gender it's a lot more fun unmentionable
so yeah yeah i
i hope that like sometimes i hope to put
stuff back into
like back into the zeitgeist like like
maybe like our listeners now start
calling their underwear on
unmentionable like i would love it to be
like taken seriously yeah like if
a girl would say to her boyfriend like
if they're getting you know
hot and heavy or whatever and then she's
like take down my unmentionable take
down my mentals i like that you know
what else another word i use a lot and i
even said it today but nobody i said
because you know when you come in
when we come in here to the studio you
could put your jacket in a closet and i
said should i put my jacket in the
vestibule
right and nobody said anything because i
think vestibule is not a word i didn't
hear you say that
the vestibule is not the closet i
i said i said should i put the jacket in
the closet in the vestibule
oh but i think it's one of those words
that you didn't even acknowledge it
because you said what did what did he
just say what is this
1940s germany no it says so like a
picture like being like
why don't you go ahead and remove my
unmentionables my invention
and then maybe he does and then she was
like i'm i'm this is going to be great
and he's like you know don't mention it
don't mention it don't mention my
inventionables yeah
speaking of unmentionables when we were
talking about homeland
yeah okay so i've been i've been
i have one quick question though let's
see you you find someone in the middle
of their fingers in their butt
right and they're taking like eight
megapixel photos of someone you're with
right i'm not a violent person right but
would you
would you would you do you think you
would snap there
and if you caught someone in the act of
trying to do something
horrific like that would you physically
assault them would you
what would happen there and if you did
would you be allowed to
would you be in trouble because it's is
that like a self-defense i don't know
like
what do you mean if somebody was
fingering their butthole and then waving
it at my face or if they were fingering
their butthole and taking pictures of a
loved one
more like the uh the secret like secret
masturbation and stuff like that if you
caught someone doing that like if you
were at the tree
with my friend and then the guy behind
you has a nice
maybe a nice 500 fill patagonia on right
so you know he's up to something
yeah you know he's got he's got his
gloves on but only one thing is cut off
right
and uh yeah no but if you caught someone
in the act of doing that do you feel
like you can contain your rage
or would you feel like you're not
responsible for flying off the handle
because i would be like i don't know if
i'd be in shock but i would probably be
so angry right that i would do something
i'm not normally
doing which is being i would never
really i hate violence so it's like
you know but i i could mention i can't
imagine
being enraged i don't know that i'd be
in ra i would be enraged but i don't
know that i'd necessarily act on it
because in a situation like that to be
honest with you because my brain's a
little wonky
i would probably get a rush of anxiety
and maybe start masturbating too
i'll put the system on trial yes yeah
and say now there's two of us flip the
script
maybe that's how we get them you stop
yeah you just immediately just go up
your own now go on my own
well no my own i don't know see up my
own ass
i'm not one of those guys never done
anal i've never even thought about it i
don't like a
finger in the butt i'm not that guy no i
don't know what it is i'm just not an
anus guy i don't understand it
i'm not never you know and listen shout
out to anybody who's doing anal
obviously the gay community the in the
closet gate community
whatever you guys want to do with your
butts it's fine by us or the straight
community or the straight community
yeah i personally don't like pimp you
have something to say i just wanted to
say
the cameras are 4k hidden look what they
sell on amazon 4k
hidden cameras wow 4k and they sell them
inside of like phone charger bricks
so don't let the guys see this oh my god
let our friends see this
whoa yeah really if i mean if you're a
sex criminal and you're watching please
just don't skip this part skip this part
because you don't want to give you any
more
ammunition i mean what are the police up
against now 4k
cameras are now in cell phone batteries
for 30 bucks you can get this
chargers yeah and then pencils like what
are these
why don't we give the why don't we give
the address the the link address for
whoever
yeah yeah for all your needs thank god
you know it's for christmas for next
year if you're looking to splooge on an
unsuspecting family
go to amazon.com i don't know if i told
this i i usually uh keep myself
even tempered again i can't remember the
stories what happened
did i ever tell you about the time with
the oh we did yes we did we talked about
what
the club we talked about the club when i
beat that guy's car with the club
did we just talk about the viper
conversation we talked about the fight
which also kfc from bar still talked
about
really shout out kfc good friend of the
show
um with the club we talked about the
viper but what did you because
i'm talking about if we talked about the
viper i can't believe i didn't talk
about the club this is going to happen
all the time
whatever we're telling it a different
way different fun i came back to my car
i used to have the club
which was the anti-theft detergent sure
if i didn't tell this thing just last
week but anyway
i did like 10 podcasts last week and i
cannot keep track of it i know it's
getting tough
i had a club it actually was broken so
it was really just like
like the lock was broken so it wasn't
really working right but
unless you're breaking into the car to
test the club right you didn't know that
it could just come right back off i just
put it on opened it
right and then if you're looking at it
then you're like oh i'm not gonna break
into that car
right because it has the club on it
right but the lock was busted so they
could have just opened it and took the
club right off they didn't know that
they didn't know that's why
but one time i i um i was gonna say how
i'm not prone to like
violence or anything like that right one
time i saw red
i came back i can't believe i didn't
tell you this but
a guy parked his car right up against my
car
hit my bumper i was like resting on my
bumper i left his car that way oh my god
so i came here this guy's car his front
fender
is resting on him he hit my car popped
up
and his fender is resting above my
bumper
and the i mean my car was a 500 car it
was a red chevy celebrity station wagon
shout out
but i already i already shout out
chevrolet yeah i also i also wrote
i'll show these pictures on here oh i
might have told it on the show
but um i we took masking tape and we
made like lightning bolts and
racing stripes on this car right and we
put
these nuts on the front windshield uh
remind me i'll give you the reasons
i'll put them up right now actually i
have them i have actually i have them i
can send i
have them right here let me give them to
you you can do it yeah i'll do it i want
you to see him but i put these nuts
on the front windshield on the back i
put caught you looking right hilarious
i used to but anyway so i got so enraged
that this guy had the unmitigated goal
to hit my car and leave it that way it
was in bay ridge by the way wow shut up
bay ridge shout out bay ridge
that i i was walking back to my car with
the guys
from my guys from the show and i was
like
look at this and i just had enough i was
like because
they can't the balls you have to have
right to hit someone's car park and then
leave it and then leave it like that and
i go well i go now this is happening
yeah and i opened the door took out my
club and i just started beating his hood
with my club
really i just beat the hood i just
dented the whole hood i was like
boom boom i was like that's all i said i
just i
walked up to the car and i started
steaming and i looked and i said look at
this guy
he he hit my car and left it he left the
scene
of an accident and they were like calm
down like no i go well
now this is happening and i just opened
the door took the club and i just
started beating his
car with the club and i put left dents
all over his hood dude it's so funny it
was like
20 years ago the car car rage
is one of those things where it's like
when you have road rage
it's it's just the maddest you can get
and for some reason cars really piss
people off
i'm talking about sal i'm mad right now
man you get mad right now i'm mad that
he and you have blood pressure issues
too you got to be careful so
i do take it you got to be a pill i
inherited it from my father but
that's another i'm going to be doing it
too yeah by the way you said before you
have a you have
uh your neck is bothering you i have a
neck pillow on would you like it
i don't know if you noticed no i
actually don't want the neck there you
go it's got a hood on it it's got
headphones
but yeah if you want to put on that uh
neck pillow so just so i limit the
mobility of your neck
but anyway i was and again
there you go so when i was a physical
therapist
i had a boss who was i can't explain to
you how nice a man this guy was
just a nice kind kind guy
so one day we're coming out of the
office and
similar story of a car is way too close
to his car maybe making contact or very
very close
it just made my boss upset but not he
didn't fly off the handle didn't do
anything this happened right in front of
me i swear to god
it was one of it was an old i think it
might have been an oldsmobile that had
the doors like an old school door where
you put your hand under the door you
know what i mean like
yeah yeah that's exactly what i have
yeah so pull it out like that like a
kind of hidden
door right so he asked me i don't know
where he goes look at this guy look at
this guy right on my car he goes it's
unbelievable
how bad people are at parking and
driving because it really makes me upset
about the cars i'm like yeah i know
what what can you do i was gonna walk in
my car he's gonna walk to his he goes do
you have a plastic knife on you
i said i said what
a pla he goes you know a plastic knife
do you have a plastic knife on you i
said
i said no oh he goes okay i i know where
this is going he goes okay
he goes he goes uh he goes all right
i'll see you you know i'll see you at
work
so i say okay but again it just was very
curious to me of like why is this guy
asking me for a plastic knife
so he goes back into the office where
there's we have plenty of cutlery in
there
he goes back in of course yeah every
respectable officer cutlery of course
yeah plastic i mean from the times you
or delivery or whatever you gotta have
coloring i'm chrissy cullery yeah
so so so he goes and gets the plastic
flatware there he goes yeah i i um
i and i'm just sitting in my car because
now i'm curious i'm like why did you ask
me for a plastic knife and
maybe i was texting but whatever was i
was in my car for at least a minute or
two
to watch my boss come back out with the
plastic knife
i see him looking around because we were
parked in like a park but there was also
like there was uh uh you know it's woods
over there it was in uh woodbury new
york
there was woods over there and then it
was a dog run so i see him looking near
the dog run
and i'm like what is this guy gonna what
is happening like it was just so curious
to me
so i see him go over he had gloves on
too by the way i see him go over
and then finally i see which i thought
from from a little far away looked like
a rock
but i wasn't sure it was a brown thing
he had went
to buy the dog run picked up a piece of
fresh dog poop with the plastic knife
took it to the man's car took the knife
and smeared dog poop
underneath his car handle so when he
when this man went to go
get his car he didn't get dog crap all
over his fingers
did it so carefully like just you know
he's done that before 100 percent he
didn't conceive that idea right now
oh my god it's a thing it's a thing oh
my god it's a thing
but it wasn't but it wasn't invisible
but please no don't do this he made it
he made it to where it was invisible so
the
the
owner of that car would have no idea
when he went to go open his door would
get
he would get fresh dog poop all over his
door candle then he put it in a baggie
for some reason i have no idea why my
boss i watched him take that bag of
dog poop and a knife put it in another
bag and then put it in his car
he put it in his own car drove away with
it i would assume to throw it away
off the side of the way to not leave any
evidence that he thinks would be
evidence
do you think there's gonna be
fingerprinting for some of this crime
yeah
evidence yeah that's i i thought you
were gonna say
so first i thought you said he keyed the
car but with plastic knife then i was
like why wouldn't he just use his keys
that's what you're gonna say he stuck it
because you said it was the pull handle
so i figured maybe it wasn't an alarm i
thought you were gonna say he stuck the
knife
in the keyhole and snapped it off so the
guy couldn't get into the car
he smeared this is even more devious
meet it smeared on the dog handles
uh the the door handle some other dog
put on the door handles i have this
information
again he's my boss so i'm not gonna say
anything like just
you never brought it up the next day he
comes in
you know we talk with the first patient
we go to the first patient
and then i say to him just to hear what
he's going to say i say um
hey i saw the owner of that of the car
come out
right after you left right after you
pulled away so the owner of the car came
out
he goes yeah he goes you know what he
goes i wound up writing him a note and
putting it on his windshield just say
hey please don't park near the car
anymore so it's all good now
no i was like i saw
he might not even know to this day that
i know but if you know jeff
i know what you did yeah you think that
that's just
an urban legend that people put flaming
bags of [ __ ] on doorsteps and people
fall for it
i don't think who's gonna be like let me
stomp this i don't know that it's
necessarily an urban myth i do know and
again if she wants me to delete this
part well she shouldn't have told me the
story
my girlfriend said that her ex-boyfriend
pissed her off and she told me one time
when she was having an argument with me
she said if if you piss me off
smith i'll do this to you too she went
on a website and sent
elephant poop to her ex-boyfriend's
house in a they package it
in a present like you think you're gonna
open up something nice and grand and you
open up and it's and it's actual real
elephant [ __ ] in a box oh and she said
that there's a website to do this how
did she even know that that existed
because the puerto ricans man that's
genius
sal yeah as you know i've been walking
around lately saying i can't even go
outside unless i have
feel like i'm laying on a pillow and i'm
literally
down to the point where i'm laying on
pillows so
what's happened is pillows are
comforting sometimes you need a little
bit of assurance or
you need to just feel better about stuff
so what i said was is i can't possibly
keep walking through the streets with a
pillow attached to my head and every
time i see a pill i have to lay my head
on it
so i said i need a human pillow and
where i found that human pillow is
through counseling
at betterhelp.com not better health
betterhelp.help.com and what i've been
doing is talking to a therapist online
yeah and they've become like my human
pillow sure it's like counseling right
it's like online
discreet counseling yes design right not
kind of
that's what it is that's exactly what it
is it is it's it's talking to a human
being
and making and feeling by the end of
that session that you're
literally laying on a pillow that isn't
there because you're getting your
problems out it's cathartic you're
talking to a
trained professional counselor and it's
correct me if i'm wrong but it is
discreet
it's most likely more affordable than
traditional counseling and i think
there's financial aid available there's
financial aid available
and more affordable it's more affordable
without the promo code
with the promo code betterhelp.com hey
babe
you get 10 off your first month my
friend 10
off a month a month what are they giving
it away they're giving it away
so they've reached out to us and said
that our
listeners can use promo code hey babe so
special offer for us they get 10
off it's betterhelp.com hey babe
that's it and within 48 hours you can be
speaking to somebody within 40 and you
could do it from any room in your house
you don't have to go anywhere you do
this all
the toilet from the toilet you could do
it from the toilet while you're on the
tushy that's another spot
that's another one oh yes that's another
one right betterhelp.com
you can do it from the toilet
betterhelp.com slash hey babe 10
off your first month what did you
remember when we were growing up
remember we were growing up
and you would you would ask for just one
cigarette what was that called oh that's
called a lucy that was called a lucy
yeah
but cigarettes are bad they're terrible
you know what we have the we have the
information now you know would be nice
yeah people that smoke cigarettes say
small cigarettes what can you do a
nicotine alternative do you know of a
nicotine alternative
well i know lucy dot co happens to be a
little nicotine alternative
wait a minute dot co lucy dot co
so you're saying no m no m on there
throw the m away
leave off the last emphasis
[Music]
promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e at
check-out don't just
don't just say hey babe to the computer
and think you're gonna get the promo
code you have to do it at checkout use
your digits to type into the keyboard
h-e-y-b-a-b-e hey babe at checkout
it is a nicotine alternative this
product contains nicotine derived from
tobacco nicotine is an addictive
chemical but you want to help yourself
maybe wean
lean off it comes in lozenges it comes
in gum yes
it comes in and and and the flavors of
the gum forget about you got cinnamon
you got pomegranate you got wintergreen
i know that's something yeah
and and the i should just i've given
some of lucy the samples that we were
sent i've given them to my aunt colleen
true story hand to god sure she's a real
35-year smoker
she's been taken to lucy for the last
two weeks not one cigarette day
she's only been chewing the lucy's
really a cigarette oh that's all and
then that's it and you and
how many people have been emptying their
purses
on on cartons of cigarettes the cost of
you know what the cost you know how much
the cigarette is now no idea one
cigarette you know how much it is how
much
forty dollars forty dollars for one
cigarette something like that so a pack
is going now for
you gotta take a pack now is eight
hundred dollars eight hundred dollars
easy for a pack
at my neighborhood at my corner store
lucy dot co
promo code hey babe gets you 20 percent
here's a song oh my god yes you twenty
percent it's almost like a pastry
it's a pastry it's twenty percent that's
a that's a french discount
lucy.com yeah promo code hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b gives you 20 plus on 20
off all products and this is this is
when
i literally almost took my first born
child and threw in the washing machine
because i couldn't believe that it was
20 off all products
including the gum and lozenges that's
insane and you know what you could do
with that twenty percent
what you could go buy what maybe a
croissant maybe a croissant with my
twenty percent that's right
but instead of because i'm i i'd like to
lower my cholesterol
and i was looking for a nicotine
alternative instead of taking my passant
and buying a croissant i went to
lucy.com promo code hey babe
and i got the gums and the lozenges and
all the products
you listened to us for maybe some
entertainment you didn't realize that in
the middle of this
there will be some important information
that you can apply to your life to start
it on a better path
phoenix arizona and red bank new jersey
i'm coming to you february 25th to the
27th phoenix arizona the house of comedy
march 5th i'm coming to the vogel
theater in red bank new jersey it's
going to be fun
okay phoenix arizona hit me with a can
of arizona iced tea
a vogel theater hit me with a salami
sandwich you can't lose christy
comedy.com
yup genius they know what's going on
yeah poop centers here we go the
ultimate gag gift
there it is holy crap sender she went to
this website which by the way if you
guys want to sponsor the show
yeah go ahead we got a promo code poop
centers just go to poopcenters.com
backslash hey babe
and you'll get two free poops two free
poops of the animal of your choosing
and that's big because other other
websites our other pockets aren't going
to get let me up
for 17.95 elephant crown it really is
different gorilla poop and then the
combo pack
you can get a combo pack for 45 bucks oh
my god you can get gorilla elephant
and cow should we do 45 let's reach out
and see if they want to sponsor the show
i mean what are we doing we're shouting
them out here oh that's great we should
reach out yeah
we should also start getting our own
yeah we should reach out that's
i mean that's insane that this exists
that's exciting
what is this like just a farm that's
looking for an extra revenue stream i
don't know i mean how can we guarantee
that gorilla poops gorilla poop but not
other poo
i can get her on the phone right now and
say hey what the hell how did you find
this you know what
testimonials can you read that because i
can't but i'd love to know about it
customer customer test customer
testimonials from uh from uh
trent new jersey say this is a gift that
every [ __ ] neighbor should get
wow then we have from chicago illinois
stan from chicago says not only was your
poop some of the finest poop ever sent
in the mail but your placement of the
wanna find who sent this and quotes card
within the poop forces the poopdon to
actually sit through the poop
only to find out that you'll never tell
them who sent them the poop oh i just
finally heard back from the poopdon
friend and i almost pooped myself
when i heard the when i heard he dug
through the poop to find out who sent
him the poop that stand from chicago
i mean someone is a genius here we go
jeff downing from lake grove new york
shout out lake grove new york shut up
you've received two packages of [ __ ] in
the last two weeks i know it's somebody
in the office so whoever is doing the
jokes
over whoever do it whoever is doing it
the joke's over quit sending me the
oh god [ __ ] hysterical what it is should
we do like a podcast war
should we send like some poop to another
podcast hundred percent
hey babe it was something all right
don't know
what we shouldn't have can you can you
hate that hey babe but they're gonna be
able to see what you said
just like hey babe snow that's
just know that somebody's about to get
some poop some animal poop and it's
it's from love oh yes yes i love this
oh this problem with their neck pillow
what's that no you know what it is
though
it actually was working terrific it was
actually soothing my neck but the hood
i was overheating a little bit you'll be
eating yeah well because i already got
this mane up here
yeah by the way and by the way it's so
funny to see some of the
the comments people just decide to log
on to let me know that i should
get a haircut or have a beard trim and i
want you to know that that's what i do i
i look through the comments to see uh
what instructions i need
for my own life for life yeah so just
just know if you told me to get a
haircut
or or stop growing my beard no i intend
to do just that immediately
immediately it's what he's gonna do i'll
yeah and i'll shave his head live on the
podcast
um so get back to homeland for a second
so homeland i am i never watched the
show
i am fascinated in my opinion homeland's
not a sponsor they're not paying us to
say this
i think homeland was one of the it's one
of the best shows i've ever seen in my
life i can't believe i'm this late to
the game i know i know i'm an [ __ ]
whatever whatever i understand you have
some gripes about the show
yeah no i love the show again watch it
in full but i have gripes i'm in season
five
yeah i'm in season five so i want to
start off with my first gripe and then
you tell me yours
sure season five i'm up to right now i
love it
i've been watching all the seasons
the one weird thing that happened and
again nobody's been able to tell me this
and it's probably a scene you don't even
remember
but for me i was like that was
interesting i thought for sure this is
going to come back
season one the very first episode
spoiler she gets off a flight
from from the middle east back to
washington dc they
show her putting down her things and
then for no reason whatsoever they show
her
going into the bathroom taking a wet
wipe and wiping off her vagina yeah
and i was just like what's the point of
that and then they never bring they
never tie it in they never tell me why
she had to do that i just said it was an
odd choice for the director to leave and
we're just gonna show that she wipes off
her vagina when she gets off a flight i
remember it because it was such a unique
thing do you actually remember it swear
to god because
it made me turn i was taken aback it
made me turn to my girl and say
what what would you wipe off like what
did it what happened to your vagina did
you swipe it off and she was like no
but let me ask you a question was the
next scene not a love not a
love making no she was at work no she
didn't go to a bar and like try to pick
up somebody
are you sure about it maybe she did yeah
i i remember being maybe
her like uh her like her bad choices and
being promiscuous like
i think i think she was like uh they
they they lean into that right because
she was
she's mentally unstable mentally she
doesn't have like a solid home life and
i think she's like uh because of her
career and everything i thought i
thought that they were like kind of like
showing you that she's
right just out there like uh she's dis
disassociated and disconnected from her
emotions i thought
so i thought she was going out for a
one-night stand and she was just doing a
quick uh
if if you got that assessment and all
that from a vagina wipe
yeah then you're on a you're on a a
different
level you're on a different playing
field than me and i i kind of feel like
in awe
that you were able to surmise all that
from a simple voucher i think you're
giving me too much credit
here we go what are you you found it up
right i mean look at this oh she's just
wiping it looking up at the ceiling and
i don't understand why if the sound was
off this could this looks like a
commercial it does look like commercials
like
like on like on the go yeah like you
know lady wipes you know like yeah
oh she's in a little black dress and
it's like have an event tonight
not feeling not that fresh yeah are you
a cia officer with a mental disability
bipolar and you're going out on a date
but didn't have time to take a shower
use this center and accidentally got
ejaculated
yeah go to vagwipes.com promo code hey
babe
yeah no i thought that that was a
takeaway from it i found it like
well it was very candid yeah so what's
your gripe
with the show i got a couple gripes uh
my biggest gripe of the whole show seven
seasons whatever it was
is i can't understand
them they talk fast and low and a lot
everything's uh
there's a lot of like whispering and
talking through teeth after all it is
it is espionage it's just me and us and
they're always like
[Music]
i put them on but also it's like now i'm
just reading
i might as well read a book i put i i
cannot watch a show or a movie without
the subtitles well i
certainly and this is where it started
this is where the impetus was for me
i could not watch homeland without
subtitles
saul berenson has a way of not
enunciating and by the way shout out
mandy potenkin
i love mandy patanka never heard of this
guy before homeland oh you know maybe
thank you what do i know man
thank you for watching it's amazing
taking this illustrious celebrated
decorated career
what is mandy potato you know for me man
this is princess bride
no is that the one with jennifer lopez
you're gonna talk to me about shrek and
you're not gonna talk to me about
the princess bride have you ever seen
the princess shrek has to be
it's a classic the princess bride is
basically uh
shrek i i don't know what shrek is is
that the one with julia roberts who's in
the princess pride
no it's uh carrie elways and
the guy from you know gary always he's
like from like uh
i don't know so many things saw maybe
but like so
princess bride baby you never saw
princesses i never saw princess bride
correct me if i'm wrong is this kind of
savage
by the way mandy patankan jewish guy
playing his character's name is in
negotiator it's cultural appropriation
we're not here for it
wait you don't know who amigo montoya is
my name is anigo montoya who killed my
father prepared to die do you know this
it's a classic bit please play the clip
in the role i'm so happy for you because
you get to see
princess bride for the first time i've
never seen it oh now i know what i'm
doing tonight
25-year classic get 5 thc.com
mandy potenkin plays this uh this what
would you call him
he's a is this mandy patanka that's
sorbets and baby
can you believe it listen to me a man
with six fingers killed his father in
this when he was young
and he always he dedicates his life to
becoming
an amazing uh guy with a sword what do
you call a swordsman
a sword a battler swordsman fencer i
don't know whatever you call
him he's a he's a warrior whatever he he
dedicates his life to the skill of sword
fighting
to find a six-fingered man he dedicates
his life to find a man with six fingers
to kill his father and so check this out
i'll tell you we're not giving so much
away
he witnessed his father's death the guy
had six fingers and then a guy as him as
a kid went took the sword and gave him a
scar
and his life's work was to find that man
and kill him
really and in the movie he finds the guy
with the six fingers and he says
i've been waiting to say this to you
since i was a little boy and he goes
my name is inigo montoya you killed my
father
prepared to die and that's mandy patel
does he kill him who does he kill him
this is it
yeah i would never in a million years
by the way how old is mandy patek he's
like 700. yeah because even
because because in in in homeland he
looks like an old man and even here it's
like he looks like he's in his mid 40s
already this is 30 years ago he had to
be like 40. yeah
yeah god but that's what i'm saying
mandy has been ride or die for the
longest time
in no way shape or form is saul berenson
played by mandy patanka his big break
oh no no no no no no no mandatory didn't
even audition for him then he was given
the part of the story
he's a big actor but i don't know if he
auditioned or not but he's he's like
he's akin to the greatest actors of that
generation i think
you've heard a man correct me outside of
homeland soul barons and pimp
i mean he's just one of those guys in
hollywood you see in everything he's
been in 150 movies
i've never seen him not a shred of him
at all
anywhere ever besides in homeland
at which i started watching about two
weeks ago and of
oh smurf's the lost village i've seen
he's
if he's a voice in smurfs the lost
village then i've definitely heard of
him
but here's my problem with mandy and
mandy if you're watching
i never brought this up mandy if you
want to come on the show patankan
i i love you i would love to interview
you i'm a huge fan
um but he has this way of being like
carrie i'm like he goes soul again with
his with his little
ramblings yes yeah so okay and i got it
and and and man
if i didn't put up with seven seasons of
that you don't want i mean he's amazing
amazing eight seasons he's amazing but i
need subtitles when i watch homeland
it's my biggest gripe
that's the big describe that's it that
goes no further than that hands down
biggest gripe i don't understand a word
they're saying did you binge watch it
did you
did you watch this as it was happening i
started in like season like i want to
say season two
season three maybe so i binge the first
two or three seasons and then every one
i watch in real time
in real time like you would wait every
one weekly son what was the day what was
the date and time
take a guess uh i feel like it was
sunday nights but i could be wrong one
time
eastern time it was late i'm i'm asking
i'm
you know it's show time
showtime is right but just say what was
it sunday's eight o'clock sunday 10
o'clock just throw it out there
it's so hard to do even the shows you
love you can't remember because you know
what i did a lot of times too i would
just watch it like once it went into the
uh
on demand like that week's on demand i
would just watch it on
demand but no i would watch it live i
just don't remember i feel like i feel
it was a sunday night show
maybe like in the prime time sunday
night but
i could be wrong you got to give me you
got to put in an official bid but okay
sunday is at what 10 o'clock sunday's 10
p.m eastern
time is sal volcano's official bid if he
gets it right it could be wrong
completely
sunday if he gets it right sunday nights
yeah date and time if he gets it right
i stay if he gets it wrong i walk off
the show right here okay
you mentioned it
oh wow there we go sunday nights nine
o'clock you guys did you say nine
i said ten close enough i'll stay on the
show how about 10
central and mountain there you go wow
there you go there you go
and then you carry too oh this is but i
will tell you this
watching homeland would give me massive
anxiety massive for two reasons
one what you said earlier i feel like
because when you watch homeland
basically they're telling you that the
world is on the brink of being
detonated at any given moment anymore
and there are a hundred factors at play
and she's diffusing all these situations
in like all the
like these situations are constantly
being diffused so while we're like
watching smurfs right and you know and
whatever it is a good time you know
putting you hanging a coat in the
vestibule yeah
there's a team of people trying to save
the earth from being detonated
and and it's just too much to think
about and they never get celebrated
they're the unsung heroes they could
pulling off an operation that took
months to to disarm the one event that
could have killed thousands of people
and their name will never be in the
paper because
it never happened and it's a thankless
job a thankless job when on the wiser
that that that everything's being
defused every moment so are we six pence
none the richer was expensive on the
richer
yeah yes what song was that um
i mean natalie sixpence nonetheless um
tiffany's kiss kiss me yeah the morning
sunlight
so kiss me run down the green
green grass that's six pencils
uh barenaked ladies no no that was it's
been
one week since you looked at me oh and
they're also thinking no that's the same
they sing yeah they sing something else
i forgot i forgot the other no but
that was all those that like when
friends was out it was like that like
like that like it was what grunge turned
into before it
and died all the way how about how about
yesterday i was in the car
we were in the i was in the car with my
family and the friend friends theme song
came out like
that song came out on the radio yeah and
oh like the full version the full
version comes around yeah and my mother
turns around to us and she goes
i bet you guys can't guess what show
this was from
i love seriously friends
she goes you guys are good i was
lyrics like this not freaking out but
like this week there was like three or
four songs i listened to and i was like
what are these like you there's
definitely you know that everybody every
single person has a hundred songs
minimum
that they they don't know
what the words were but they
we assign words yeah
and then that's good enough for us yeah
and then that's what you're saying your
whole life
until one day you see a lyric or you
hear clear or someone corrects you
right and there's like you have any
songs that you know like you do yeah
like when i was a kid i remember like
the reggae song it was big it was like
action
[Music]
my mind
yeah no i that so i would yeah what
about you what songs for you
i got um um oh you know what i found out
uh
someone just told me what this was you
know kat and i joe yeah
yeah i found out what he's saying what
are you saying i didn't know it what's
he saying what do you think he's saying
um i've been running around a long time
ago where did you come from where did
you go where did you come from
now how does
[Music]
i've been married long time ago what did
you say before i've been married a long
time ago
yeah um i don't know i
i always go beat up
ready set up what did he say if it
hadn't been forgotten not joe
i've been married a long time ago all
he's saying is if it hadn't been for
continental
what he's saying that son of a [ __ ]
what right listen to it
it fits if it hadn't been forgotten not
joe
i've been married long time ago where
did you come from where did you go where
did you come
[Music]
i'm blue if i was green i would die i
thought i i think she'll do that
are those the lyrics
what does that mean i don't know dude
it's got to be something it's got
something to do with homeland though
i'll tell you that
i'll tell you that much it's all
connected
black cat janet jackson i don't even
know the song what do you mean
i don't even know the song on the edge
not a phrase
it was one of our hits black black cat
the only janet
janet jackson song wait wait before you
play the lyrics don't even look at that
because i don't want to say but can you
play the song okay oh we have to
uh you can't play the song damn youtube
rules
i have 23 top wrong lyrics
okay you've probably been singing oh
waterfalls don't go chasing waterfalls
360 of the rivers in the lakes that you
used to shout out chilly by the way my
my she's what do you mean actual
misheard lyric waterfalls i always
thought they were singing don't go
jason waterfalls instead of chasing what
what's kind of stupid [ __ ] that's an
ass i thought i was always i thought
okay who's jason waterfalls
give me the beep boy isn't free i know
that one give me the beat boys and
freaks
i want to get lost in the rock and roll
drift away that's toby yeah i mean again
so far we have give me the beach give me
the beat boys and free my soul people
thought give me the beach boys
yeah that's stupid what would be the
point what else do we have mr lyric
last night i dreamt of soft bagels but
it's really last night
i mean these are just stupid these are
actual don't even bleep this these are
[ __ ] whoever these people are yeah
that's it you didn't even get a hey babe
we got lucille kenny rogers who just
passed away r.i.p
when i was a kid i heard kenny rogers as
saying you picked a fine time to leave
me lucille with 400 children and a crop
in the field
the actual lyric is you picked a fine
time to leave me lucille with four
hungry children so it's pretty morbid
can he oh bugaboo destiny's child let's
just do one more bugaboo destruction
i love this i got something for you here
we go
uh it was number five bugaboo's destiny
child oh that's
here we go bugaboo there we go oh yeah
miss heard lyric is when i was younger i
thought the lyrics of destiny's child
song bugaboo would break my knees so i
can't move because you a bugaboo
the actual lyric is break my lease so i
can move
tell mci to cut the phone calls break my
lease so i can move
i don't know i don't even know what that
is okay okay you want to talk about
lyrics that i don't understand but i
know the lords too
yeah culture club okay time
right let's talk about it let's talk
about it you know the song
time won't give me time yes but time
makes
lovers feel right like they got
something am i about to sing it
yeah i think you could sing it yeah like
they got something real
yeah but you and me we know they got
nothing but time and time won't give me
time what does that mean no idea
time won't give me time time won't give
me that time won't give me time
so maybe it means that like no matter
how much i time passes
how much i want extra time i can't get
extra i can't get it is that what that
means time won't give me time i would
think that that's
what it means but i will tell you i
don't know if you've ever met boy george
have you ever met boy george
no but i i got a shout out culture club
shout out culture club one time i did
the larry wilmore show the nightly show
with i don't
remember the conversation yeah i did it
i was a guest with boy george and camron
the rapper cameron who cameron came on
the show in a full turban never
addressed it
so you could look it's a full full
turban boy george came on the show
with the top hat that was abraham
lincoln level yes and i felt like a jerk
off for having nothing on my head
but anyway boy george literally great
guy
he says um he says to me we're talking
or whatever
and then he says to me he says to me
very very high chance my love
you were conceived to one of my songs
and i was like
okay he goes there's a very probably
right
that is that is very he's emboldened
he's involved it's very i like it
you know it's confident but i don't
think i don't find it to be off-putting
you also gave me his phone number to
reach out any time and i've
texted twice and they both texted not
delivered really
good boy i have my phone he gave me his
phone number and i never
you know unless he has it there it is
yeah if he gave you his phone number
why would it be wrong you know i don't
know i don't know but he did that yeah
it was me him and catherine
you call boy george right now yeah can
we try to call boy george
yeah call him uh i mean yeah nightly
show was four years ago but let's do it
let's do it i forgot who i was on the
nightly show with
but i got a 100 chip at the end i kept
it 100.
can you call i mean this is um we could
ask him directly what does lyrics mean
yeah you know here we go so time will
give me time
so that means i feel that means like no
matter what you can't manufacture time
you're not getting more saved
uh time won't give me time but time
makes lovers feel like they got
something real
so i think that uh is time and illusion
then
so well time is an illusion time is
arbitrary time was made up by human
beings it's not a real thing
so time time but you and me we know that
they got nothing but time tell me what
you think this means
time won't give me time okay but time
makes lovers feel
like they got something real but you and
me both know they got nothing but time
and time won't give me time
the only thing that i could say is maybe
it means something to the effect of
lovers think that time is real but we
all know that love is just chemistry and
its chemicals and
as the chemicals fade away and you pee
them out the love will go away
so they think that they have this time
but they really don't because the love
is
it's it's a clock that eventually goes
away because it's chemical
but you and i have time because we're
not in love
i don't know but you know the song
though i actually don't can you just can
we just cut this part i can just play it
for them because this song is a
this song is a banger i don't think i
can write a song
yeah for me no i wouldn't even know
where to begin i could never rap
write a song i can't sing i don't even
know how to play an instrument i don't
even think my thumbs would let me play
an instrument
i've wrapped a little bit i'm not saying
i'm around
i'm not saying i have any skill with it
i'm not saying i'm not saying any of
that i'm not saying anything
but when i've had to like
karaoke or whatever like i don't i don't
i think i could like
i could passively rap why i put enough
feeling into it
that i i have a bit of a like i'm not
just like
you know like hip hop hooray oh
yeah you know yeah you know i i have a
little bit of
confidence in me to you know to wrap a
few balls to wrap a few bars
yeah no i couldn't do i don't think i
could do any of it
i'm not singer you know i don't even
doing stand-up like being on stage like
i kind of just feel like it's not even
like a real talent like i feel like when
i watch somebody say
my point is when i watch somebody sing
and dance and write a song like oh that
that's actual talent they're an artist
anytime i get called an artist i'm like
what are you talking about i go up there
and i make up stories about myself
what do you mean over here no but yeah
but i i wish but do you
do you wish that you could like do that
is that because that's my number one
thing i wish
every every song i hear that i love
obviously i love the 1975 i also love
a new band or not a new band but not as
well known band called the band camino
love those guys
every time i'm listening to their songs
even whitney houston when i'm listening
to a whitney song
all i do is imagine myself being that
person singing the song i've imagined
myself being whitney houston
yeah singing singing any of her hit
songs
because she exudes soul being whitney
you said singing so emotional
to the lyrics of singing about you know
i guess so i'm on
time i think of you
i get so emotional
ain't a shocking what love can do
shocking what love can do i've imagined
myself
literally in 80s gym clothes and women's
spandex singing that song to a crowd
full of people as i'm walking on the
elliptical
yeah yeah you know what i always want to
do too yeah something she does is when
they like hold the side and they go like
oh my god yeah she does that
well well you know what i noticed that
about you because there's been some time
there's been a couple of times
where you've posted something on on
social media or maybe i've been at the
show but there's been a couple of times
where you've been doing a show with the
jokers to the packed out arenas and you
started with a song
but you sing the song as if you're the
lead singer of the band
oh we just closed we used to close with
billy joel's uh well we closed with
every tour is a different song no and i
think there was another song with with
steve byrne
um um oh mr brightside mr brightside
yeah
he's in the killers i'm watching him
because you're like you're putting the
mic
down and looking up like he thinks he's
in the killers oh because what other
what what other time you've been able to
do that no no i want to feel that
feeling and so i'm like play a song at
the end i'll sing the whole goddamn
thing you give me one opportunity
to get on stage in front of 10 to 15 20
000 people
i'm gonna play a song and make believe
i'm the artist singing that song right
after i finish my comedy babe i did it
every night
for for eight like all over the world
actually probably more than 80 cities
all over the world the last tour we
closed with billy joel's
you may be right right do you know that
song friday night
oh man we used to scream it into the mic
yeah the whole crowd is singing it
and it's just fun it's a nice little
label well that's the thing nothing in
my opinion gets the crown moving in
kills like music even the the
best stand-ups even you know we're
bigging a practical joker's fan or even
watching like a chappelle
if you put a musician before after they
can't possibly move the crowd
as good as the musician no it's just it
just does something to
do you know actually what dancing is
like the the technical scientific
definition of dancing
is your brain processing emotion you
know your brain gets so
overloaded with your neurons get so
overly
overloaded with stimulus from the music
that your brain and body has no idea
what to do so it starts to rhythmically
move
in an effort to try to dissipate the
overload of shock the brain is having
that's amazing that is what dancing is
that is amazing
yeah how wild is that yeah it's the
purpose of uh releasing energy or simply
taking the light so that's just like
you know but if this feels like your
brain is like you have to move
that's what your brain is doing it's
getting an overload i have a challenge
for you guys maybe at the first live
show
homeless pimp challenge what is it you
perform an original song at the first
live show you two
there it is
[Laughter]
challenge accepted do you know who that
is martha plimpton oh i thought you just
called him martha pimpton i did
because of martha plimpton oh who's
martha plimpton she's an actress that
was in the goonies and many other things
oh shout out shout out the goonies my
lawyer is in the goonies
oh yeah yeah chunk shout out to plumpton
oh she's saying your name in like so
many different ways
yeah the other day i
[Laughter]
i okay so that's what we're gonna do the
very first hey babe when the world opens
when we do the very first hey babe live
show we will perform at the end of our
show
an original song that we have created oh
singing you too crazy
we wrote it and sang it wow you're gonna
write it sing at the end of the very
first hey babe show so you got to be
there the live show
yes this rate will be 2025 yes
i remember there was a podcast that you
like i don't know in just
as a joke you were like something
something something oh the podcast ends
right now and then
everyone was like don't in the podcast
don't in the podcast yeah did i say that
on one of the episodes i don't know
i don't know i just did it again with it
if you don't get the homeland right
and they think it's a threat no no no we
are not in the podcast this is god this
is going for a long time
trust me shout out paragon ad company
we're gonna do this what about what
about when you uh what about when you
have to sing a song to someone because
you're like trying to remember like know
what
you're like oh do you know this song
yeah and then people like i'll sing it
sing it and then do you have confidence
to sing it in that in that moment
yes and no like i feel like certain
songs like if it was written
the song i could just hit it because
like i've now i can't sing but i've
memorized
the way whitney houston sings that i i
can just feel like the best chance i
have it sounded like
me knowing how to sing is singing some
type of whitney houston song but other
than that that's
the most challenging thing you could do
i know it's insane she went to houston
has one of the saddest songs i've ever
heard in my life which one i have like
five
songs that if you played i'll cry i
swear to god
i swear to god if you played like a
handful of songs that i
tell you right now i could stare at you
and i will produce tears streaming down
my face
it's something biological chemical with
me and it happens but wouldn't you
for me there's only one song to make me
cry really just one song and one song
only
the national anthem is that right that's
it god bless you
god bless on patreon yeah yeah wine i
have like
five six seven eight songs okay one of
them is whitney houston's all at once
all at once i'm dr
yeah uh i forgot the rest of it but i
just know all that she went
yeah oh i'm drifting on a lonely
i know we're singing a lot during this
but just sing along you know
all at once oh this is a this is a this
is the this is the line that guts me
what is it
um all at once
the smile that used to greet me brighten
someone's else
someone else's day she took your smile
away
that's so sad that's very very who wrote
that song it wasn't whitney
was it maybe it was i hope it was i love
whitney
can i just say something though yeah you
can't
i love whitney houston like you can
imagine
i love her love her songs love it so
much
i'm just not the kind of guy who ever
wants to wait online for anything i
would never camp out anything
if they brought whitney houston back
from the dead and she had a concert at
msg
i wouldn't even wait online for that i
would just see the length of the line so
i'll just see her next time even though
she's dead
and they're going to put her right back
in the ground yeah i'm the opposite you
will wait
not only will i wait i mean i i'm like
bucket list i have to see this person
this per at any cost right at any cost
any cost i'll pay a premium
i'll wait online how about this and
you're by the way one of the most
nonchalant guys
for huge events of that i've ever met i
remember we were all hanging out in
vegas we're having a great time
you guys were staying in an extra couple
of days we're all just chilling
i had to go i forgot where to go
nashville or something like that to do a
show
and you say yeah just go you know
there's nothing going on
i call you get back to new york i said
hey remember i i left on a friday at a
small show with zany shout out saying
he's coming up great
i said what did you do he goes oh he
goes what do we do what do we do oh you
know what we actually wound up going to
the elton john concert we hung out with
them all night i said
i said what do you mean you went to the
elton john countries yeah we went to the
elton john concert we were right there
we saw him got to meet him yeah it was
great but what'd you do where you were
you zany's
i said yeah i didn't meet him but but we
had but we had our own
section which is was awesome yeah right
above the stage turns out by the way
that was as good buy
as yellow brick road farewell to never
gonna perform against salvation
30 hits in a row it was it was a
a magical did you do it in his pajamas
too or something wild
no what was wild was it came out later
that he was pissing his pants the whole
time
what i think performers do that
apparently or he doesn't he was wearing
like a
i don't know if it was a diaper or just
some type of very absorbent he has to
pee
so much i mean he's paying three hours
and maybe he's up in age i don't know if
he has it has it
he's the exact opposite of you he's the
exact opposite once a week
they came out he would he would sing
this is i swear to god this is what we
do he'd sing a song
every song was a massive hit he'd sing a
song everyone knows it's the last time
he's seen it live basically right
at the end of every song 30 songs
three hour concert at the end of every
song he got a standing ovation he got
out from
under the piano a piano went to the
front of the stage took
a bow to a standing ovation 30 songs in
a row
30 times and he had this chalice it was
a bucket it looked like it was a
spittoon
and he kept hawking spit and loogies
into the splatoon
the whole show he'd be like goodbye
norman jean
but i'll never feed him
wow and he kept doing it like what is he
doing i guess he just has to clear his
throat
and he needs he needs a way to do it in
style yeah and he was
hocking into a spittoon for three hours
straight every
song standing ovation then a week later
it's in the news
he came out and said yeah i was just
pissing and [ __ ] the whole time
and you were there you were there and i
left
you sal was there and i i left early to
go on a southwest flight that connected
through chicago
yeah no dude that's uh i mean huge
moments look at elton john
the best any any and he has stayed true
to the retirement he's never come back
so you
you've genuinely think that was it that
was it let me tell you jay-z retire and
then kept coming back
who didn't jay-z retire but then he just
kept coming back yes but elton john
stayed true to his word
i don't know actually about jc he
retired didn't jay-z say he was retiring
he wore a diaper and pissed himself
during the las vegas gig
there you go elton john once wore a
diaper and pissed himself during las
vegas
only only someone like sir elton he
owned it
he told everyone he's like get this i
had to piss the whole time wow yeah
yeah i had to pee the whole time the
little peepee head well there you go i
mean let's
what can you do you know but so i'll
tell you this
so there's a song you know this one tell
me if
you know this song because i love a good
falsetto okay
as well that's one of the things i wish
like if you could have one person's
voice who would it be
one person would be like sinatra would
it be like ray charles would be like j
justin timberlake does it have to be a
guy no i guess not well then again
i i want to know your reality if you're
singing chops could produce a voice
let's do male and female
okay so if i could have any voice of
anyone whatsoever at all i know i've
talked a lot about whitney houston
whitney issue would probably be number
one or adele would be number two
for a guy for a guy i would think that
i would either want to have um chris
stapleton's voice
oh what kind of swiss tennessee that or
the other guy
ray la montague lamontagne i'd like to
have ray lamontagne he's awesome
great voice he's awesome yeah i'd like
to have those two guys voices
yeah that's good he's like you are the
best
thing they heard another one right like
yeah yeah that's good i would i would
say
whitney's hard to top but i would go
back maybe a little bit
why maybe do aretha wow or maybe just
like a billy or an ella like a billy
like one of those like a throwback i
think but then for a guy
man i got to tell you who's in
contention oh justin timberlake's in
contact justin timberlake because he
effortlessly can do different genres and
he has a falsetto that'll knock your
socks off justin timberlake might be one
of the most
talented individuals overall of anybody
i've ever seen in the human
race ever yeah because he not only can
he sing and dance shout out justin
timberlake he's
uh he could probably have been a
saturday night live cast member
without ever without ever being justin
timberlake
obviously you know does the show you
know he acts he could do anything
like who justin timberlake to me some of
the most talented people
of all time all across the board jt is
up there just
telling out the yin-yang like you can't
believe yeah yeah like like
choose your career and he just
accelerates he can just do whatever you
want jamie foxx is like that
jamie foxx could be the next person i
said jamie foxx unbelievable
anything that guy does unreal shout out
to movie soul i know we talked about it
last possible yeah that's that's what's
great
so great did we talk about solo in the
podcast i i you know why i'm talking
about stuff i'm coming or going
i have no idea we talked about i've
talked about soul all week i've seen it
three times
about who i talked to it about yeah i
thought i thought the lead character
looked like roy would junior i was
rebuffed on twitter
no i could see that no because i finally
watched seoul because i don't watch
pixar
and you were in my head and on christmas
day i got the disney challenge because i
want to watch mandalorian shout out i
made lauren shout out bill burr
yeah and i was like uh what is soul it
came out today and i go
let me give pixar a whirl by the way
people were enraged
when we called a disney movie a pixar oh
sorry guys
gotta put the keyboards down jesus
christ yes but yeah no but i like
justin's falsetto
i dream you know you see you dream about
you singing whitney i want to sing
when he goes uh if i wrote you a s
symphony oh yeah when when you see how
much you mean to me
look what i do like no it just it's so
like soulful
for me and i know it's close i know it's
close because obviously obviously i
would just
i would assume i feel it when he sings
it i'm in my car alone i go
i'm making faces i'm like in the car
going you're not here
if i could trade places and have
experience from a point of view
it's of of one moment in history of one
group of years in history it is not even
close it's a guarantee you can ask me
right now you can ask me 20 years from
now you could ask me 20 years ago
the answer would remain the same and i
know it's very close to you because i'm
assuming he's a friend of the show he's
a very close friend of yours met him a
couple of times very very nice guy
but to be have been in the 90s a member
of nsync
oh sure number one thing i would do and
you know the many times
you know joey fatone obviously very well
known for friendship the many
the the times when i've met him and been
in his presence you know through you
all i've thought about is i would love
to do i would love to just
i want to get inside his i want to crawl
up his ass and get in his brain yeah
because i want to just see
what he saw in the night i've heard a
lot of you i've heard a lot of stories
and unbelievable he'd be a great guest
on the show come on tell stories it's
wild to hear stories i mean
i mean think about the level of what he
achieved
what he saw and what he experienced i
mean there is
the smallest fraction of people that
have seen him done what he has seen and
done
there was a time he played a 90 they
played 90 000 seats
a stadium like in like japan every
corner of the world
i mean they were the most famous beatles
they were the the most famous five men
at that time at the time in the world
that whole screaming pass out like that
michael jackson beatles
because to me they were bigger than the
backstreet boys yeah i believe so i i
would i would
i don't know i would argue to say that
they were the most popular boy band of
all time i think they probably have
nothing against nko tv
or backstreet boys or any of them not
none of them but or the jonas brothers
here's oh so here's a here's a good
falsetto song let me know if you know
this okay ready
and i don't know all the words but i'll
do my best
um
you still been so crazy
when you heard my brother's home
[Music]
you were my one temptation
and i got this feeling again
i guess i'm so confused about you
oh i feel
so in love oh baby
what can i do i've been thinking about
you
i've been thinking about you
huh man thinking
i feel so in love oh baby
what can i do i've been thinking about
you
that song no
every week we're coming at you every
week thursdays 11 a.m eastern time hey
babe
tell your friends check out the promo
codes
i'll be at seoul joel's in roysford
pennsylvania
january 16th we've added a late show
january 17th
this sunday we've added a 6 p.m show the
next day's mlk day you guys are going to
have off great cause
go christy comedy.com or sol joel's
with an s dot com roysford pennsylvania
the heated dome in the middle of
pennsylvania thank you
all right i got uh january 26th uh the
missouri index starts season three
january 26 to miss january 26th the mr
index starts season three
that's on uh uh thursday uh just on
tuesday nights at 10 30 on tbs
february fourth season nine even
practical joker starts that's no that's
oh sorry
i'm all jacked up tuesday uh the mystery
index is on 10 30 p.m tuesday nights on
tbs it starts january 26th season 3.
it practically jokes season 9 starts on
february 4th thursday nights at 10 p.m
and then i just want everybody to check
out if
you if you're loving no press check out
our other podcast too it's called taste
buds
it's the thing i do with joe derosa we
battle for foods it's fun it's different
it's short and
you'll love it thank you
hey babe hey babe
hey babe